cette génération de gauche comme de
droite a beaucoup vécu avec les médias
et c'est vrai à droite comme à gauche du
souhaite intéresser à la politique mais
tu n'y comprend pas grand chose je ne
vois pas vraiment ce qu'est la gauche et
la droite alors qu'on en parle tout le
temps politique je m'appelle sylvain
drame mais je suis professeur de
sciences sociales en belgique et dans
cette vidéo je vais tenter de répondre à
ces questions et de t'expliquer
clairement ce qu'est la gauche et la
droite en politique définir la gauche et
la droite n'a pas vraiment de sens dire
ce que fait la gauche est ce que fait la
droite de manière définitive est
impossible car la gauche et la droite en
politique sont des réalités qui ont
évolué et évoluent encore aujourd'hui
par exemple certaines mesures comme la
nationalisation d'entreprises c'est à
dire le fait que l'état prenne le
contrôle d'une entreprise privée était
perçu comme une décision de gauche dans
la deuxième moitié du 20e siècle mais
elle est aujourd'hui considérée comme
une mesure d'extrême gauche
[Musique]
dans le même ordre d'idées la perception
de la gauche et de la droite peut varier
d'un pays à l'autre par exemple le et
mer le mouvement réformateur partis
politiques belges francophones est
clairement situé à droite mais si ce
parti évoluer aux états unis avec le
même programme il passerait pour un
parti du centre voire de centre gauche
enfin les représentants politiques et
leurs parties peuvent également évoluer
et se déplacer sur l'échiquier politique
au fil du temps il faut donc bien faire
attention quand on utilise ces termes de
gauche et de droit car ils n'incarnent
pas une réalité fixe mais plutôt un
positionnement lié à un certain contexte
cela étant dit je vais vous donner
quelques clés pour être en mesure quand
même de dire si une décision ou un
acteur politique est plutôt de gauche ou
de droite être à gauche ou être à droite
c'est relatif c'est relatif à la
position d'autres acteurs face à un
enjeu cet enjeu peut être des valeurs
qu'il faudrait respecter l'égalité est
une de ces valeurs qui polarise le champ
politique la gauche est souvent
identifié comme le camp de celles et de
ceux qui défendent l'égalité la personne
qui considère que tous les humains sont
égaux et situés plus à gauche qu une
personne qui accepterait certaines
inégalités de ce fait la personne situés
plus à gauche sera plus facilement en
faveur de mesures qui permettent une
plus grande égalité entre les êtres
humains comme par exemple un impôt sur
la richesse permettant d'aider les plus
ni un peu au détriment des riches
cependant certaine forme d'égalité sont
elles mêmes plus à gauche que d'autres
une égalité pure et simple de richesse
entre les individus interdisant toute
différence serait une forme d'égalité
très à gauche à côté de cela l'égalité
des chances qui acceptent certaines
inégalités à condition que les chances
de réussite entre les individus soient
les mêmes sera perçue comme une
inégalité plus accepter à droite voire
défendue par certains hommes ou femmes
politiques se présentant clairement de
droite sur ce continuum des valeurs où
l'égalité forme le pôle de gauche et la
droite envers une autre valeur cardinale
la liberté entendons nous bien être à
gauche ou à droite ne veut pas dire
refuser la liberté où l'égalité mais en
cas d'arbitrage entre ces deux valeurs
chacun accordera une importance plus
grande à l'une des deux valeurs au
détriment de l'autre qui permettra de
situer cette personne sur l'axé gauche
droite par exemple si on veut plus
d'égalité entre les individus il faudra
mettre en place des lois qui empêchent
certains comportements discriminatoires
comme les discriminations à l'embauché
ou construire des mécanismes de
régulation comme l'impôt sur la fortune
qui réduira en partie la liberté de
chacun en faveur d'une plus grande
égalité dans l'autre sens en
garantissant une liberté plus grand aux
individus comme le droit de fixer
librement des salaires dans une
entreprise on peut créer des inégalités
de richesse pour des personnes qui
exercent peut-être le même métier bref à
gauche on préfère réduire un peu la
liberté pour une plus grande égalité
tandis qu'à droite on préfère diminuer
un peu l'égalité pour une plus grande
liberté cependant on constate parfois
que des partis dits de gauche n'agissent
pas pour une plus grande égalité que des
partis dits de droite renie la valeur de
la liberté comment expliquer cela ce que
je viens de vous dire au niveau des
valeurs de liberté et d'égalité est un
grand principe structurant mais n'est
qu'un modèle très général en effet il
existe différentes formes de gauche et
de droite et on peut très bien être de
gauche sur certaines questions et être
de droite sur d'autres d'ailleurs
certaines études réalisées en france
montrent que seul un tiers de la
population est cohérent sur tous les
enjeux en 1997 une étude du cevipof
montré que seulement 16% des personnes
se déclarant de gauche et 14 pertes pour
cent des personnes se déclarant de brad
était en accord avec l'ensemble des
positions de leurs comptes sur les
principales questions économiques
sociales ou sociétales pour avoir une
vision claire de ce que sont la gauche
et la droite il faut bien comprendre
qu'il existe différents clivages qui
structure le champ politique ces
clivages évolué avec le temps et dans
l'espace ce qui rend parfois la
politique difficilement lisible un
clivage c'est une division profonde et
durable de la société sur un enjeu
majeur l'opposition gauche droite est un
clivage politique qui est lui même
construit sur différents autre clivage
qui évolue dans le temps généralement la
science politique identifie trois
clivage qui sont à la base du
positionnement gauche droite moderne le
premier de ces clivages est un clivage
économique fondé sur la manière dont
l'économie doit être organisé faut-il
que l'état intervienne pour réguler plus
ou moins fortement l'économie comme le
suggèrent les politiques de gauche ou
faut-il permettre aux entreprises
privées d'agir en toute liberté comme le
demandent les politiques de droite nous
pouvons nommer les deux pôles de cet axe
intervention de l'état à gauche et
liberté économique à droite d'un côté on
veut plus d'état de l'autre on veut plus
d'initiatives pour les individus et les
entreprises privées le deuxième clivages
et l'opposition entre nationalisme et
humanisme universel on sera considéré
comme plus à droite lorsque l'on
considère que la nation auquel on
appartient est quelque chose d'important
qu'il faut défendre qui possède une
certaine identité à l'opposé on sera
considérée plus de gauche si on est
défenseur de l'humanité dans son
ensemble quelqu'un qui défend le droit
des personnes immigrées et donc plus à
gauche que celui qui pense que les
immigrés ne peuvent pas avoir autant de
droits que les nationaux le dernier
clivage repose sur une conception de
l'être humain d'un côté du continuum
l'être humain agit en fonction de sa
propre nature il est donc
individuellement responsables de ces
actes et doit être sanctionné en cas de
faute la peur de la sanction empêche les
individus d'entrer en délinquance c'est
plutôt une vision de droite à l'opposé
toute action humaine est considérée
comme une construction sociale l'homme
est une éponge fortement déterminé par
son milieu et peut développer certaines
potentialités ou non les individus ne
sont donc pas toujours à 100%
responsables de ce qui leur arrive la
meilleure réponse assez un problème de
société l'est la prévention et
l'éducation qui empêche les individus de
commettre des actes graves il s'agit là
de la conception humaine propre à la
gauche une réflexion identique par
rapport à la société peut-être une base
du clivage gauche droite pour quelqu'un
de droite il y a un certain ordre
naturel parfois hérité de dieu un
équilibre entre le bien et le mal qui
doit être maintenu pour faire société
alors que pour la personne de gauche
toute société est une construction
sociale dans laquelle ce sont les
individus eux mêmes qui décident
ensemble comment la société doit évoluer
et donc qui définissent le bien et le
mal c'est à partir de ce dernier
clivages que des positions en faveur ou
en défaveur du mariage homosexuel des
droits lgbt qi plus la dépénalisation du
cannabis ou de l'avortement sont
considérés de gauche ou de droite on
peut résumer ce dernier clivages en une
opposition entre progressistes et
conservateurs les uns souhaitent que les
lois évoluent avec la société tandis que
les autres veulent conserver les
traditions afin de bien fixer tout ce
qui vient d'être dit je vous propose un
tableau récapitulatif
vous aurez donc compris que définir la
gauche ou la droite sans aucun repère et
de manière générale est une aberration
car ce sont des réalités qui évolue et
qui ne sont pas toujours homogène on est
de gauche ou de droite par rapport à un
thème par rapport à un contexte
historique et géographique donnée par
rapport à d'autres acteurs politiques
étienne choix aiguë chercheur cnrs en
sciences politiques déclarent à ce titre
pour qu'une position soit de gauche il
n'est pas nécessaire qu'elle se situe à
gauche de manière absolue il suffit qu'à
se situe un peu plus à gauche que la
position de droite et vise personne je
vous remercie de votre intérêt pour ce
travail de vulgarisation et je vous dis
à très bientôt dans une nouvelle vidéo
de la société consacrée aux sciences
sociales et pourquoi pas à la science
politique à bientôt
[Musique]